uh we'd like to start with a
poll and we've been asking
this question we'll be doing several
polls during the
presentation and this question we've
been asking
since the beginning of the pandemic
just to check in and see how people are
feeling so
um for those of you on webex you should
see the polling widget
and uh we welcome anybody
on live stream to comment
with their answer we're just going to
give
about another 10 or 15 seconds for this
so
and i'm gonna go ahead and close the
poll
get your answers done please
and
well thankfully the vast majority of
folks today are feeling well
um for those of you who are
in the third category we hope that this
presentation
will be informative and will help
brighten your mood a bit
and with that i am going to introduce
prem lieutenant colonel primevos retired
the ceo of prehonje ventures he is a
qualified international business and
life
coach credentialed by the international
society for coaching professionals
of singapore and he has more than three
decades of professional career
experience
in both the indian armed forces and in
the corporate world
so we're very pleased to have him here
today and prem
thank you for joining us i am going to
turn the presentation over to you so
thank you so much thank you so much
stuart for that introduction
and good morning good afternoon and good
evening
to whichever part of the world you are
it's a delight to do this
sharing of presentation in which i am
going to share my experience
great looking forward to do this okay
let's go straight into the presentation
can hear this can you see the screen i
hope you can see this
yes we did yeah
fine so how to sharpen your interview
skills as you move up in your carrier
so this is a very wide subject probably
take three days if you really want to
cover it
but today i'm just going to do it in
about 40 to 45 minutes so less than that
and we will handle those
aspects that is specifically when you
are going to move up
your carrier the interview skills there
is far different
from any other interviews that you
normally attend
so we're going to do another poll now
and so we want to know from
the audience your profile will do this
in two parts the first part
are the first two questions
uh and prem i think if you click on your
presentation you'll reveal the first
questions okay
yeah so which country are you editing
this session from so that's the first
part of the question
and the next one is how much experience
do you have
so you have four options just select one
of that obviously
less than two years three to five five
to ten
and greater than ten years
you give yourself one more click to
reveal that second question
all right here's the results of the
first two questions
um what country you're joining farmers a
very long list and i'll
i'll try to take a look at that and
share some of that with you
but for experience we have a fairly
experienced audience today
the biggest number is
people with more than 10 years
experience now we can move on
to the second two questions uh prem if
you click your slide yeah we'll go then
yes we'll do that yeah let's
go ahead and do that a couple more times
yeah there we go
approximately yeah
and once more if you look please
so these last two questions are now up
on your screen the approximate number of
interviews
you've attended and what you feel is the
most common reason
for failure in an interview
and we will close the poll in five
four three two
one and
so the largest number answering the
first question
have done fewer than five interviews
which is interesting compared to the
experience levels
and the most common answer among the
reasons for failure is
an inability to articulate my answers
but the other reasons were also cited
so with that let's continue the
presentation
so we can close the poll right
let's start okay so interviews are here
to
say now during the dance time i remember
very distinctly that
uh you know everybody used to be very
proud of
going for the golden watch you know
after 25 years 30 years depending number
of
years that they have put in experience
to
so those were those times and if you
really don't need
any interviews after that after you do
your first
interview but today the world is far
different from what it was
in the past at least 10-15 years
now you change jobs in your professional
lifespan at least three to five times
minimum and some are even more than that
so it's very rare that you will ever
find somebody
going for 20 years it's it's more of an
exception today
so if that be the case it clearly means
that
interviews are going to stay it's going
to be part of your life
so therefore like any other skill that
you have skills
like that you learn the soft skills that
you learn how to do your interviews well
so that you get the job that you want
is also a skill that you need to be
constantly
working on which means you must be
having a perpetual
master cv with you in which all this
information you can't constantly keep
upgrading because you never know when
you're going to shift
into a next job for a better growth
opportunity
so it's going to bottle system is going
to be part of your life is going to be
part of your body if i
may say that so interviews are going to
say therefore what should we be doing so
that
we are acing it up in our career
so we'll go for the second audience poll
over used to it
and this poll is
what is the most important factor in
selecting a candidate
hold on for a moment while i activate
the poll
in this case select your top reason
and again we have about 20 more seconds
okay
and there is a clear favorite answer
share that with you in a moment
well 60 percent got it right yeah
it's perfectly that this is the reason
why
you need the rest are all important
there's no doubts about it
but potential to do the job well is what
actually clinches the interview
okay
so what do you what do we have to expect
from
this session so i'll quickly take you
through that
first is the classification of
interviews throughout your lifespan
there are predominantly three
classifications we'll take a look at
that
the importance of perception matching
the perceptions
of the candidate and the interviewer
there is a perception that needs to
match
what is that we'll take a look at that
then obviously the mastering the art of
preparation
the secret of excelling in interviews
and creating the edge to ensure your
visibility
now i've marked this in blue base
basically because
the complete presentation till the end
these two aspects will always be
part of every slide what is the secret
and how do you get that
edge so that you're visible to the
interviewer
when i talk about visibility of the
interviewer is once the interviews have
gone
you stay in the mind of the interviewer
that is what is meant by that disability
next comes the influence today of social
media
in the interviews how influential the
social media can be
in letting you be selected for the job
and finally how can i help the question
answer questions just before that
uh from across the globe thanks to
technology you can always reach out to
me so we will see how do we do that
now coming to the classification of
interviews there are pre
three predominant classifications and
this is just
broad classification the first one
obviously is the
entry level interviews which is with an
experience of one to two years or
no experience you know the interns the
freshers the grads and the postgres they
all come into this category
the second is where the junior and the
middle level interviews take place and
that's when
the junior is between three to five
years of experience
and five to ten years of experience for
the middle level
where the middle level managers are and
the final one
is the senior level interactions which
is for
people who are more than 10 years of
experience and we have
about 38 percent of them who are
attending today that's wonderful
right and uh this is the entire
interview spectrum that we have
if you noticed in the senior level i've
mentioned it as
interactions and not interviews because
at that level
it is more of an interaction there's
always an exchange of mind which is
happening by its vision so
it is a lot more informal and that's why
it's called interactions
next we come to what is the need to
excel in interviews why would you need
to have that burning
of fire in your stomach to excel in
interviews
i'll share some statistics which glastro
has shared
the corporate jobs you know this is an
average okay across the world
at the average says that if you get 20
250 resumes
of which four to six are likely to be
interviewed
and one is going to get the job you see
the ratio
so out of approximately 250 there's just
one who's going to get the job now this
may not
hold true for every job that you're
applying for but
this is entirely an idea to give you
that you have to take every aspect of
your interview seriously
to make that shot
now coming to the importance of matching
of perceptions now this is
something which i have personally
thought to do and brought this into my
presentation watch very carefully
as to why this is the importance of
matching of perceptions there is a
candidate
and there is an interviewer now between
them
the interviewer has a perception of what
is the job expectation
now most of it would have got translated
into your
job description over and about that
the interviewer and here when i say
interviewer it also means maybe a panel
too
the perception of apart from the job
description is what is there in the mind
of the interviewer
as to what kind of a person are they
looking for what kind of a candidate are
they looking for
and in the candidate you have a
perception of what can you
deliver for that job description that
you got for the position that you are
applying for
so you have a perception when these two
perceptions
meet of all the candidates who are there
the one whose maximum match happens is
the one who takes the job
so this is the core of understanding
why a person gets selected i just split
this into the perception
because now you have to do everything
that you can
to match the perception of the job
description and what the
interviewers got how do we get to know
that is what we are going to see in the
rest of this
presentation the first clue obviously is
the job description
now two steps for winning interviews
broadly speaking there are three steps
that you have
the preparation the interview per se
and closing and follow-up of the
interviews
now i have a poll just before this and i
want you to
pay attention to these three steps what
is the most attributable factor
choose only one option and here are the
options
again if you're on webex you should see
the poll widget if you're
watching live streams you can enter your
answer in the comments
and we'll close the poll in about 10
seconds okay
apologize to the people who say they've
not seen the poll widget
do you want to uh now
put the pull up again it's it's
it's fine it's it's it's a fluke of
webex that sometimes
some people won't see it and i apologize
for that
so 61 of you say performance in
interview
is the most important factor and
34 percent of you say that preparation
is the most
uh the most important attributable
factor
right so this is a myth we're going to
break and i'm going to tell you why
okay let's take a look at the next slide
all the three are important there's no
doubts about that but performance in
interviews definitely obviously that's
where the whole crux is but
something even more important
okay and that is the preparation
okay to me in my experience of having
countless interviews that i've done
first across the spectrum right from the
entry level to the
junior middle and the c suit in all of
these
60 to 70 percent success comes from how
you prepare for that interview
right and you have also mentioned that
you know lack of confidence
37 percent of you said that there is a
lack of confidence
and the reasons of failure and the
inability to articulate
now if you do your preparation and what
goes into it
that automatically translates into a
very enhanced level of performance when
you do your interviews and what are
these things that you need to
prepare for so let's take a look at that
see we must have a master
resuming or a cv resume obviously is for
one page maximum it could go to two but
predominantly it's one page and the cv
like most of you know
should not exceed more than two or three
as you
go up in your career your resume a
master resume can run to maybe five six
seven eight ten pages that is fine
it's okay and that's why when i said
that you have to
keep maintaining your resume throughout
your career any good things that happens
any achievements you do
please put it on into that resume so
your master resume can run to five six
seven eight pages
but there is a jd specific point the
every job that you get you gotta tune
this resume or the cv
to the job that you're getting you
cannot
use the masters survey or the master
resume or a cv
for every job that has come you can't
spray it like a sprinkler on the grass
it doesn't work you're very lucky if it
works so each job
has got to highlight what can you
contribute in that
from your cv so the words in the cv all
the resumes should match the job
description
and that's how it gets picked up because
the the
application tracking system the ats some
of some of the companies use that
they only pick up what are the words
that is matching with the jd
so that's very important then you must
list your strings and your areas of
improvements your strengths are
something that you're very good at over
the years that you picked up
you may be good at match you might be
good at calculations you may be good at
people handling
you may be good at communication even
good at articulation
put all of that as your strings and
there is a reason why i'm asking you to
do this
and the areas of improvement
all of us are human beings we have all
our failings you know shortcomings
so we have to do something to improve
that because as you keep going up
in your carrier every aspect of your
personality
needs to have its presence
for getting the job done so therefore
you must know your areas that you need
to
improve upon and this comes from the
previous experience that you had
and why is this important is the next
question you need to prepare
a list of question and answers both
technical
and behavioral because if your job is
technically oriented you must
have your questions based on your
strengths and area for
improvements for the technical aspect of
it and the behavioral aspect of it
a little more on the behavioral aspect
because as an interviewer in my
experience
i found behavioral questions are the
ones which
actually brings out what is the
personality
or what is it that drives a candidate
and there is an entire subject by itself
most of the
talent acquisition people know that
behavioral bei
they call it the behavioral uh
entry interviews this is event
interviews this is a
this is a kind of a subject by itself
where
if you are a master in it you will be
able to assess your candidates very well
what does a job entail and how you can
contribute the first point that i
mentioned about
everything that the job description
gives what can you contribute to that
is what you must prepare in your answers
to these technical and the behavioral
questions
then your growth plans which obviously
indicates your enthusiasm
okay now you've got to work on your
doubts and consciousness this is where
that
lack of confidence and you know the
inability to articulate if you have
concerns that obviously pulls you down
so what you need to do is write down
honestly to yourself what are your
doubts what are your concerns
and thereafter how do you want to
address it
how do you want to convert that
answering of that doubt or a concern
into a positive answer
that's something which is subject by
itself right
that will dilute the negativity your
lack of confidence nervousness it brings
it down
this is very important have you been to
a show where you find an actor i'm
talking about drama
every actor who has got his lines
correct
you are instantly find that appealing
but if somebody forgets a line or
something you know that there is
something amiss
something like that happens when you go
for your interviews if they ask you a
question and if you're not very sure of
the answer
then it comes out in the way that you
answer so if you do your preparation of
list of questions and answers
and if you list out your strengths and
areas of improvements
and you sit in front of a mirror close
the door
and rehearse how you would do it i do it
at 58 i
sit in front of where i rehearse this
presentation two three times before i do
it
it's that important okay so you have to
rehearse it and phenomenally
your your confidence moves up
check it out for yourself and a good
night's sleep
and look forward to a very pleasant
experience for the next day when you go
for the interview
now there is something called must-know
topic at
all levels the entry level the the
junior and the mid-level
and the senior level and this is
pertaining to today
so i want all of you to make sure that
you know this
and this is the challenges the pandemic
has thrown
you must know what are the challenges
that you faced as an individual your
team has faced
the company has faced and the industry
has faced
you must know this inside out and how do
you cope
this what is the mechanism of coping
mechanism that you adopted
and how did you resolve it this is very
very important
and the future assessment of the
challenges what are the challenges
and what is your assessment of these
challenges all these four aspects
you as an individual team company and
the industry
and finally this just before this you
have to know
there is a predictability and
uncertainty in all you do
because of the spanish you should make
your assessment of what can be
predictable for the future
and what is uncertain in the future in
all these four
aspects and how are you going to
recommend your resolution for that
this is important at all levels be it an
intern
a graduate or a mid-level
lead and including the c-suit this is
very very important
now we will go specifically what is the
must-know basics at each of the slips so
let's take the entry level first
your academic knowledge is aligned to a
job description
you must do that how is it your academic
aligned
the second what are the additional
skills that you have picked up
during the academic curriculum which is
over and about that you know because of
pandemic you may have done
courses certifications that one
learnings from projects seminars
simplism they're all trending ones
what have you learned out of that how
would you like to contribute to the
company from
your existing knowledge whatever your
knowledge the company knows that you are
fresh
you come from the academy they know that
you may not have an experience
so how can you contribute with that
knowledge
where do you see yourself two three
and five years from now you must have
that go to an internet
go to the uh google it out as to what is
your carrier profile that requires
the lifespan of your carrier you will
get all of that whether you're an
architect whether you're a
engineer whatever you want to be soft
skill that you picked up in college to
help you carry you know you may be good
at
getting funds you may be good at
articulating good at debates which means
you can
these are these are qualities that's
very good for customer service
marketing and sales and things like that
so these are something which you've got
to highlight
and then you have to highlight what's
your contribution to the society
environment because today you are a
whole rounded person
you're just not going to just do your
job so what is part of
volunteering have you done it shows what
is
how do you care for the society how do
you care for the planet earth
and then of course your passion
professional and personal both the both
are equally important it
it tells you a lot about your
personality too
then let's go to the junior and the
middle level the must-know basics
what additional qualifications and
certifications you have done
apart from your formal academics in this
three two
maybe five to ten years of service other
than other than that you may have done
some management development programs
from reputed institutes of
i've done some courses certifications
whatever it is
you must see and tell them as how you
could apply it
it's that's more important how could you
apply it
and the technical and work efficiency
measures that you
adopted as a leader to improve your and
your team's efficiency
as an architect you may be an individual
player but still how did it
how what are the measures you have
adopted for the efficiency levels
then your experience from individual
contributor
to leading a team that transition is
very important
where from us when you join us in it as
an individual person and then how you
went about leading a team
a very challenging and a lot of
experience you learned that if you can
share that
you will involve the interviewers
obviously that's why i said adequate
examples
the value you can bring from your
experience to the current
job description this is the clincher it
what can you bring as value to the from
your experience to the current job
and examples of achievements excellence
from your journey from the entry level
right to your current profile
and your scope of improvement in your
areas of somebody might ask you
and how are you handling it right so
that is very important
now let's go to the senior level this is
at the c suite or just below that
people who are more than 10 we've got 38
of them this is one question where
you're likely to be asked a lot in your
interactions
your industry perspective and your
network competence at that level
at that level it is more of how much
networking are you capable of because
your stakeholders
have multiplied and therefore dealing
with them is very important and
networking helps
a great deal at this level what is your
experience going to
add value to the profile
unlike a youngster who would have joined
who's purely academics here it's
more and more and more of your
experience which is going to add value
please do share that and what is your
vision to take the business unit or the
department
to the next level here most of it is
vision when you go to the higher levels
beyond 10 years
it starts here in the brain and from
here how are you able to convert it into
a practical application for your teams
for your department at the business unit
that is the vision that they are looking
at
additional knowledge other than
academics and its application over the
years
like what you picked up over the course
uh certifications and all of that
now the experience and i've marked this
as professional storms that you have
weathered
now this experience of what are the
difficulties and challenges that you
have gone through these years
that is more important than the x number
of years you have put in
if you ask me if somebody with 10 years
of experience have
gone through some serious challenges as
far as the industry is concerned
than somebody who is 20 years and who
had a very smooth sailing
i would go in for a person who's gone
the tent was weathered the storms
that because that person knows what it
means
to face challenges and overcome them
sharing failure stories and how you
bounce back a lot of people keep telling
the good part of their life
they don't talk about where they have
failed
if you really ask me all of us fail some
time or the other otherwise we are lying
or we must have dropped from heaven
there is no other reason
if you you must have failure stories and
how did you bounce back
which is more important that's why it's
highlighted in blue
your ability to connect across a
spectrum
that's from the junior to the highest
person in the company
that is a skill what happens is that as
you keep growing up
you have lesser and lesser number of
friends
but as you go up and carry you can't
lose touch
of your grassroots so how you're able to
connect with that
that's a phenomenal quality that you
need to bring at the very senior level
and the ability to influence and inspire
leadership only comes if you're able to
do that
your ability to provide leadership to
people smarter than you
right a lot of people
are successful very highly successful
are people who have
peop who have in their teams
who are much much smarter than
themselves their leadership is how to
make
maximum potential use of the smartness
for the goals for the objectives or
for the vision of the company so that is
where it matters
so in the art of preparation another
thing which i want
uh you to understand is this know thy
company now this is more
not for the higher uh not for the senior
lot this is more for the junior a lot up
to three to five years of service or
even less than that
so when i asked them okay do you know
what what do you know about the company
that you've come for an interview for
us so have you gone through the website
so they said yes we've been to the
website okay tell us about the company
and believe me not more than three to
five sentences can they go about it
no that's that's pathetic you can't be
joining a company where you have
not you know done your homework to find
out what is the company about
right some of the aspects that you can
look at it is you know
the industry standing where does your
company stand in the industry this
you can get it from the website even if
it's not in the out even it's not an
updated website you can still
get this information what are the
achievements that the company has
got who are the competitors at least
three to five competitors and where is
the company standing vis-a-vis the
competitors in the market
financials right what is the market
capitalization
the profit levels how are they gear mark
the funds for future growth
what are the r d uh levels they're going
all of that in the news some of the
companies are in the news for good and
bad reasons it's okay but you must know
what is the reason
and if you have some questions on this
please do ask and definitely culture i'm
telling this culture
separately because this is very
important today a misfit in a company
can be a serious
liability it can cost the company heavy
if they don't pick up the right
person who is a culture fit okay we will
discuss about this little later
now what are the steps to the winning
interview we come to the interview per
se we just talked about
preparation i spent a lot of time in
that because that was important
now the interview per se
the impression and the body language you
never get a second chance to make a
first impressions
today there are interviewers who
feel that making a first impression is
not that really important
okay because we are more important to
see how good you are
at uh at what the job that you do so
your first impression doesn't really
matter
but out of 100 people there is a
research that has been done
in which 43 percent of the hiring
managers
they have made the impression in the
first
nine seconds of taking a look at you
when you enter that
meeting room for your interview and
they've decided
subconsciously or consciously that
whether you will
be the one to make it or not now
would you want to take the risk to know
whether that interviewer
is part of that 40 percent or the 60
percent order less than that
so that's a that's a huge risk so better
to be that you
carry out the kind right kind of
impression nobody's asking you to look
like a model when you go for a
interview but a clean bearing a very
confident looking bearing and
being yourself if you be yourself your
impression
is naturally bound to come in your body
language
smart dressing therefore it's space it
stands and ends with the security gate
i'll tell you why if you're a people
connect person how you treat the
security guard when you went to park
your vehicle
how you treat the lobby how you treat
the receptionist
how did you treat that prank lady who
came and gave you
a cup of tea or a glass of water it
matters
a pleasant smile square shoulders relax
straight back don't stiff like that
that's going to make you hard but if you
have a squat shoulders and relaxed
straight back irrespective of whichever
level you go it puts
confidence into your voice because your
stomach muscles have been pulled in
and therefore it instills confidence
small points
but these are phenomenal points that
will
make you you know in decimal points a
better candidate than the others
an enthusiastic rating of the day wait
to be asked sit down and unbutton your
jacket
if you button your jacket i've seen a
lot of people do this and they look like
a toad you know that
it bellows up like this and it looks
very and the person is very
uncomfortable you got to be comfortable
when you sit down for the interview
so that's why this point i made it now
it's purely from my experience
let them initiate the conversation some
people like to use silence to see how
you are
how uncomfortable you could be but you
should maintain that cool the patience
shift your gaze if there are more than
one person there to two or three
panelists shift your gaze when you
answer your question
and you could start with the person who
asked the question
shift the case and then finish with the
person who had asked a question
okay that's one way of doing it now
that's for face to face now we are more
and more
into smart virtual interviews now in
this virtual interviews
uh you would have noticed or if you
experienced now in the past year
plus that if there is a disruption in
the
virtual connect it leads to an
irritation therefore
invest in a very stable internet
connectivity a good mic
camera lighting from the front not from
the back
minimum disruptions you know as going to
the extent of making sure somebody
doesn't ring a doorbell or you have
somebody to attend to that
you know lock your doors you know tell
people that you know they
you are going to at an interview so
there is less noise background lines
then check the background you know i
don't have to say much about that okay
let's not have some
uh funny backgrounds behind copy of a
resume or a cv you must keep with you
just in case
you have to clarify something and your
etiquette some disruption there could be
an
ambulance that goes by or maybe an
aircraft is flying by
you need to stop when you speak when you
are responding to a question
and then apologize uh politely and go
ahead
small things but very important all of
these pre-session check something like
your pre-flight checks
very important you know like the
password and the id you must have
it right in front of you written down
somewhere it's not that just two minutes
before you open it and then you find
that this your
computer is crash and you have to
restart things like that so just start
10-15 minutes before
and be ready you can mute your mic and
mute your video and whenever
the interviewer comes you've got to be
present there that's the right protocol
you have to be present before the
interviewer opens up a set
and then thereafter your
interview starts whether it's
face-to-face interview
or an interview on virtual there is just
one shot
that must come when you get into the
interview and that is
i can do it no other thought in your
mind
all your faculties all the five senses
your
sharpness of your mind your ability to
listen to the questions
rightly and answer to the point all this
is will come if you confidently say to
yourself
with an affirmation that i can do it the
t
just remove it it doesn't belong to you
now coming to the behavioral questions
so
there are so many ways that some of you
know that there's a star technique of
doing but this doer technique is
something which
i have invented myself so this doer is
because you're going to do that
interview so that's why doer is more
useful i'll give you an example of how
to answer a behavioral question with
this dual technique
let's say you've been asked to raise
funds for a project
right or for uh for a volunteering uh
when you were in a college or when you
were
in the company as a part of your social
responsibility you've been asked to
raise some funds okay so what is the
situation you must describe that so you
say that uh the task is to raise
funds and the objective is to raise say
50 million dollars
or sorry 50 000 in the next
uh say two months so that is something
that is an objective that you have
and how did you go about executing it so
you made a list of
what are the uh who are the people who
can contribute and you targeted them
the influential persons in your town or
the region that you worked
what are the timings that you need to go
and do this and when you need to call on
them
and you just didn't go knocking at each
door so you were very methodical that
comes out when you answer so therefore
how did you execute it so you can
mention that in the e
and what is the results that you've got
how much money did you make 40 000
or 50 000 or 60 000 whatever the results
are so when you use this do a technique
you have to you have you noticed you are
very clear about answering this question
and you are
answering all aspects of the behavioral
questions there
so do a practice of this
make about five to ten behavioral
questions are likely to be asked
based on the jd and practice your
answers and you'll do extremely well
believe me
practice telling your story very
important
now what do they look for in interviews
this culture fit i will give you an
example right
the culture fits see the culture in a
company could be hierarchical it could
be
a new generation company you've got to
understand it could be a mix of both it
could be
a global company it could be purely
local or the only region
you've got to understand that look for
that and that's the culture fit that
we're talking about
i for instance when i came from the
armed forces very disciplined
and methodical precise process oriented
but when i joined the company as head of
hr
the average age was 27 and i was the
only one who was
above 50 and believe me i went to seven
iterations with them which each of the
crowd
at each level and below all of them had
said that they wanted me as a head of hr
and that's how i joined them so
adaptability how can you adapt into the
culture
that's very important if you feel you're
not going to make it don't take the job
three things you shouldn't say there are
so many things you shouldn't say
but three things you shouldn't say don't
badmouth for heaven's sake
how lousy the company was they they pay
us firm
pay masters the boss is the lousiest
creature walked alive on earth
i mean don't ever do all of this because
you will do the same thing in the
current company
right and that's a good enough reason to
reject you
don't sound desperate i'll do anything
for the past 10 minutes i don't have a
job
just give me whatever job whatever
salary you want these kind of things
don't work
because the company is looking for you
to contribute and when you
tell them what you can contribute you
automatically you get picked up for the
job and that is how you earn the money
that you want
right don't go into with the begging
bulge don't
use only adjectives you already touched
upon it in the doer
the behavioral question use it to a
technique give proof don't say i'm great
at
uh people connect i'm great at us you
know
getting sales give proof of how you got
sales
so last is the closing and the follow-up
right and in this one
ask them if they've got what they want
to know this will give you this is a
question that you must ask okay
have you got whatever you uh you would
like to know from me when you ask this
question they will tell you if there are
some gray areas
and then you can amplify that area when
you're going to then and that puts you
in a better spot
right what are the next steps when it's
the next interview what level it is
and how soon can you hear who are you
hearing it from
and definitely say thanks some way of
thinking thanks is either email or some
people use thank you notes which they
leave
it at the reception to be delivered to
the person who's interviewed you
and thank the staff who hosted you it
goes a great way
for uh people person people connect that
you have
and finally your interview is not over
until you leave the premises
okay right because you're being watched
make an assessment of the interview when
you get back what went well what did not
how can i
improve going forward right this is very
important analysis of that and
call up the person who organized the
interview and thank them for the
opportunity in case you didn't make it
request them to share why you could not
make it or what are the areas that you
could improve
now not all companies share this
information but if they share with you
don't go into an argument with them or
try and justify yourself now
just take that feedback it's very
important go back
reflect upon it and see why did they
make that opinion
right close with an opportunity even if
they give you something negative say
thank you so much
and if there's any future i will work on
whatever you have told me and i would
look
look forward for an open uh opportunity
in the future
close it with the doors open getting
depressed
feeling sorry especially for the younger
ones
is not an option
resolving to improve yourself is the
only option that you have when you
don't get into the interview that you
got remember
sometimes you win sometimes you learn
okay you don't lose you learn and no no
so social media is very influential
today a lot of team leaders or leaders i
would like to take a look at
their social profile how are they so we
ask for social profiles
and that's public for if you're not
asking for your personal one with the
public ones
and what i'm going to show you is i'll
quickly go through this what are those
ones that just
resulted in rejection because of your
social media
behavior your social media post and
what's written red is the percentage
people who got
rejected somebody did this uh survey
drinking using drugs 38 percent
you know discriminating cover uh
comments race gender religion
post it too frequently it means you've
got a lot of time
lied about your qualifications poor
communication skills
you know the language that you've used
that that denotes there
link to any criminal behavior you know
something that you are
supporting or things like that and the
last three that is you know sharing
confidential information bad mouthing
and
lying about your absence this is for
people who have got previous experience
these are the percentages that indicate
people have got rejected i'm sure you
may not want to be part of this
so if you have anything of this in your
social media please go ahead
and delete it so therefore last
just reach out to me this is how i can
help these are my contacts you could
you know take a screenshot you could
take a photograph of this this is my
contact
you can reach out to me on my phone i'm
on whatsapp and
on the telegram my email this is my
leadership with boss is my website
please go take a look at that and i
also have a youtube channel called was
vibes and
you can access that too it's got lot of
carrier enhancing videos in that
i've just started this just few months
back okay
and reach out to my social media helps
again take a screenshot of this i have
my own page
on the facebook of leadership with
brainwash
linkedin i would love you to connect
with you because this is a wonderful
opportunity to be part of
to connect with the globe and the
instagram
this is not much there and this is the
book that i have written how to sharpen
your interview skills
this is a book which is interactive
you got pages in that where you can
write your notes i have i've given lines
and
extra pages for you to write to all
those questions that you have mastering
the
art the mindset of the secret perception
matching
tips of having an edge creating
visibility all of this that we discussed
it's more in detail in this book it's
available on kindle it's also in
paperback
paperback currently in india but in
about a month or so it will be available
in u.s as a paperback otherwise it's
across the globe it's available on
kindle
the technique of answering frequently
asked questions and not so frequent
questions and
and uh i've also given space for you to
write your own answers there
and that's why it's interactive i've
also put in a qr code where you can
capture the checklist of
the cb and the interview preparation
that i have put there
so that you don't have to take the book
along with you your your
mobile or your tab is good enough for
that and virtual interviews we've
already touched upon it much more detail
in that
and how to excel there and this is
what's more important about the book is
that i have taken views from
global ceos and chros chief hr officers
and what is it that makes them click
people what about people that delights
them to
select for interviews and what puts them
off i've given asked east of them three
three of them
and that's available there straight from
the horse's mouth
okay so my book got reviewed in indian
institute of
this is an institute which is among the
top 50 in the world
and they have reviewed this book uh this
is the links for you to take a
snapshot of and you can get this the top
one is for the
paperback which is currently in india
and the other one is
on the kindle it's across the thread
across the globe
currently about seven countries have are
uh have i have got readers who have
taken over a reading of this book
so i'm also a coach and uh like was
mentioned
by stuart in the introduction and
therefore i thought i could use this
opportunity to
help you do an interview session a
coaching session for you for one hour
on zoom one hour i can reach out anytime
you want whatever is convenient
and i would like to present my free book
either as
a kindle form or a paperback depending
on the availability that is there
and please take a a screenshot of this
because this is the context that is
already there earlier
this is my whatsapp number and my email
id you can reach out to this
please share your name your email id and
mobile number and we can connect
i can put you through an interview
therefore you can up and ace your
chances of going through an interview
if you have uh areas that you need to
improve upon
right so with that other students
let's go for the q and a
excellent um we have quite a number of
questions
that have come in and um
here's one that should resonate with you
guy time asks
i'm a from a defense background plan to
switch
to my career after 21 years of service
in aviation maintenance and safety what
are a few things that
i need to concentrate right so
obviously uh since you've been in the
aviation that's that's the industry that
you need to look for
and you need to do at least much before
you leave you need to work at least if
you really ask me
you have to understand the industry and
you need to read a lot about it to go to
the internet find out what is it
that's trending what is the technology
which is trending in that
industry what are the uh what are the
qualifications which may be far
different from what you did
in your uh in the defenses in the armed
forces it's far different
so what are those qualifications how do
you do it what are the institutes that
offer them
what is the timelines that you need to
uh do that so how do you plan that
how do you work that backwards what is
the trend
of the kind of jobs that you can do so
i'm not sure
what was your i'm sure if you're a flyer
then obviously flying is an option for
you but if you're a technician or if
you're
something on the technology part of it
would you like to excel that would you
want to move to the r d or for that
that's something that you need to work
on so i'm going fast because i can take
more questions i hope
i'll answer your question uh we have
several people who've asked about
how to handle a gap in the resume
anything from a few months to a year or
so
especially during the pandemic period
what advice do you have
for them when they're asked about that
yeah
perfectly fine so we all understand most
of the companies
we all understand there's a pandemic
people have lost jobs
uh because they have to be let go
not the choice of uh of not a very
favorable place everybody understands
that so you
don't have to really perturb about it
but what is more
important is that what have you done
during that gap
to upskill yourself if you have done
courses you've done certifications
you've read books
even if you're not done with your read
books you read about industry
what did you do to you know improve
yourself the areas the gray areas that
you had
and how did if you're able to speak
about that that's good enough right and
some are really genuine reasons you
could have gone on imaginatively
somebody would have been seriously sick
somebody would have been uh
you know unfortunate uh god forbid that
somebody would have passed away in your
family these are reasons
genuine reasons and all of us are humans
we all understand that
but if you have a valid reason how did
you cope with it
that is what makes you important
excellent
are there ways that you can you talk
about
making that first impression in the
first nine seconds
and uh are there
things that you can do to improve
the perception if something went wrong
in those first nine seconds
okay so firstly you won't know that
whether the perception has been
famed in the mind of the interviewer in
the first nine seconds you have no idea
right but what you can do definitely is
to
prepare for that first impression when
you open the door
your body language how do you stand you
know how do you greet them
how do you open the door how do you
close it in
in case of face-to-face interview and if
it is virtual
how do you greet them when they open it
and how do you present yourself there
okay how do you adjust yourself what is
the quality of your
technology when you were doing that and
that's why it's very important you know
today if you're working for somewhere
you would buy a car you would buy a bike
you would invest in clothes you would
invest in so many things but
you you just want to use your camera or
you just want
you're not investing in in technology
that
goes into virtual high you got to do
that get hold of
lan instead of just doing it on wi-fi
and just at that moment you froze yeah
but if you do this
and the pleasantness the way that you
greet with
with enthusiasm in your voice and the
smile on your face
that's good okay one more thing you may
be having a
mask on your face today when you enter a
room just slip down the mask
greet them with a smile and greeting of
the day and put the mask back on
for your own health okay and that's how
you do it
okay we have a question from a linkedin
live
viewer how do you enhance your
conversational skills in the english
language
conversational skills in english
language if that's if you're
in a regional person how do you answer
that is that the question
did i get it right if they feel if they
feel less than confident in their
english language skills
what advice would you have for them to
improve
see really speaking not just english any
language for that matter
when you speak what you have to speak
you will speak
naturally the problem comes and and this
needs that this can't be corrected at
that interview it has to be
much earlier the problem comes when you
are
you are thinking in your own language
and
converting that into a translation into
an english and then speaking it
the gap comes there the
station there so you're going to start
thinking in english the best ways that
i've had in my last company as head of
hr i've taken sessions and i've told you
just listen
just look at this very quick example
look at a baby how does a baby learn a
language
it's not going to read a book how to
learn english in 30 days
it's it's picking up by its senses the
eyes the ears it is connecting
correlating
that's how you learn the language that's
how you learn english you got to do that
much before not by going and attending a
class
on how to learn english
learn this learn to speak yourself don't
worry whether they're going wrong that's
where it is
very good um we have a couple of
questions from people who are
switching uh domains switching into
different industries
um and one
for example uh asks about switching from
this
senior level jobs in in the travel
industry
and trying to switch into other
areas but um
lack of success is lowering his
confidence right now so
what advice do you have for people who
are
going from one field to an entirely
different field maybe on the strength of
the
the new skill certification or um
a new educational experience that's
wonderful question and it's very
relevant today
there are industries which are not doing
well and will not do well in the
uh because of the pandemic so therefore
you need to switch
you may be quite senior enough right so
what you need to do is that whichever is
your passion whichever drives you
go into that and in that you need to do
a lot of homework
uh that's there's no doubt about it
because what's happened is that
uh at your level you have earned a
number of
uh years of experience in that
particular industry
now if you're going to a different
industry you need to fill that gap
but believe me there's one thing that uh
that all of us
understand that as a leader the
leadership qualities
are by and large the same whether you
are from an industry a
or an industry b all that you know to do
is to
learn the rudiments of that industry
that's why
you had karma who was earlier in the
banking industry
he was heading the commerce and he was
adding that industry and then icsa bank
and then he moved to infosys to totally
a software company at that level i'm
just giving an example at that level
those qualities of leadership
are more important your adaptability to
understand what is the
next industry that you're going to go do
a lot of homework do studies speak to
people
speak to what is the requirements that
you need to do for that role
you have to do a lot of proactive
learning there
and that's very important and believe me
it can be done it's not something that's
not and everybody understand that you're
coming with that
that background so they will give you
that much of ropeway when you join in
them
right and the thirst that the thirst and
the burn in your stomach to learn
i think it will take you forward don't
hesitate
excellent we have a couple of questions
about virtual interviewing and tips for
that and specifically for example one is
if the interviewer doesn't turn on their
video
should you turn yours on um but
what are some other points about that
and and other things about virtual
interviews that you can advise
okay so if the interviewer hasn't turned
on his video
uh it doesn't mean that you gotta turn
off because when like you remember i was
telling you that uh
the virtual interviews in fact
interviews why you do face to faces to
see
how do you respond how do you we may not
know what's the reason why the interview
has turned it off we have no reason
and neither do we need to bother about
but you keep your
keep your unless they tell you to turn
it off too okay or you're feeling very
uncomfortable you could ask
should i keep my video on just ask them
let's play as simple as that
but i think you should keep it on
because then your body language and the
way that your answers
gets captured even though they may not
have turned it on
okay we're running um
a little over time so i'm going to
close it out with one last question and
i apologize in advance to everyone else
whose questions we didn't get
to um there are so many excellent
questions from the audiences
and um this last question is uh
are there any specific job portals or or
tips you can give for where to find job
opportunities
yeah so uh there are a lot of jobs the
predominant ones are like
in india there is this monster.com nokri
and there are some there are some
some ones which are not very popular but
they're very pop in the region all you
need to do is just google that and find
out what are the top
sites that will give you uh for job
portals and they will give you a whole
list of them and depends on the region
what is working there that will come out
there that is
a better way of doing it right so just
go ahead and do
that and that will tell you what is the
percentage some of them have got
a premium services where they ask you
for
a certain amount of money so that they
give you more features
where they they profile you better than
the others and all that
so uh really what's the success in that
it can only be asked from people but
definitely that's if you don't have any
other options that is definitely the way
to go
okay very good and that concludes the q
a portion of the
presentation um i'm going to go ahead
and take the
sharing back from and i will close out
with the last
few announcements
that's all right with you
and
yeah uh stuart i just want to thank you
and simply learn for having given me
this opportunity to connect with these
people and it's wonderful
and thank you so much you can go ahead
yeah
i will i will do that and you'll get
another chance to uh
to say goodbye in a moment what we're
going to do is a
final poll and this is the as
premise mentioned lifelong learning
and skills acquisition is so important
so what we're going to do is
um for a moment while i
watch this poll
here we go
it's two basic questions what are the
skills that you're most interested in
learning from this list and
what time frame what time frame are you
looking to do that in
there's an expression that says when
would write
when would right now be the right time
to do something
but that
there's a lot of truth in that so
we'll give you about another 10 seconds
and three two
one
i will share the poll results
and the inputs from project management
is the most popular category for today's
audience um but there's interest in most
of the other skills as well
and it's it's heartening to see that um
largest number of you said right away
is the right time to begin and so
with that as i
unshare the poll um i want to again
thank prem for this uh presentation i
have dropped his contact information
into the chat window
several times so you can reach him there
oops
sorry um but here's his linkedin
um at linkedin he's uh pram
9b dashvoss.2059b and so if you just
type in
premvos you should be able to find it on
the list
um we would also like to remind you that
learn has a free program called skill up
where over 600 of the skills we offer
um are available through video self
study more than a thousand hours of
video content
in areas from data science to project
management to digital marketing
much more you do receive completion
certificates
when you finish these free courses
and i have dropped that
link into the chat window several times
as well so please take a look there
and check that out and check out our
other
more formal courses with which include
live instruction and hands-on
projects and labs
and our next webinar
is wednesday of next week june 23rd
in the digital marketing domain
and this webinar is
a master class on researching keywords
for the different digital marketing
disciplines seo
pay-per-click and content marketing and
each of those has a different
requirement
so this is a way to
learn the nuances of the different
skills i've dropped the link into the
chat again
for that webinar registration
and
with that the webinar is pretty much
over we want to thank everybody here uh
pram we want to thank you and we want to
thank our audiences
both in our live webinar
webex and um our live streams on youtube
and linkedin um we invite you
to connect with simplylearn at our
social media channels
at simplylearn on facebook twitter and
on linkedin and we look forward to
seeing you
at future simply learn webinars again
thank you so much thank you everyone
thank you stuart especially for you
okay and uh you're welcome
and again that concludes the webinar so
at this point we invite you to
log off of linkedin we will send you a
recording link
via email tomorrow to a recording of
this webinar
we cannot share a powerpoint from pram
because it is proprietary to him
but you will get a link to the youtube
recording of this webinar
and for those of you who have made it
through
at least 30 minutes of today's session
will be emailing out proof of attendance
certificates over the weekend
so please expect to see those uh on or
before
monday and with that
we have concluded the webinar thank you
you